because of biden i'll tell you that
right now
i'm not a political person but he's
kind of messed things up ah
why is it so expensive a little intense
what insane right
6.75 students
so yeah i just saw that so i'll probably
be putting probably ten dollars in this
just to get out of here that's crazy
that's too much
yeah i think this is enough
this is the only gas station in
mendocino it's probably been here
probably near 100 years
one of the first gas stations and
obviously it'll be the last one if it
closes how much is it today 678 a gallon
for regular
yeah
stuff
[Music]
i think it's
crazy it's terrible it's uh
it's not necessary i'm retired myself so
i live on fixed income so these things
matter to me and my generation group you
know
i worked hard like everybody else in my
situation did to be able to retire
but
if prices keep escalating like it is
it's it's going to make it very
difficult for everybody in california in
the country as well well the gas prices
in california are crazy it's a problem
yeah the price of everything is going up
but uh you know i feel for people that
have to commute to work for a long
distance it's made it so much harder to
get from place to place um and i feel
like i spend most of my money on gas
these days like gas and food so it's
just
kind of frustrating
i was pretty shocked when i looked at
the price i was expecting it to be like
four or something it's a little much you
know i mean especially
with so many people that have been out
of work and things like that and we had
kids in their 20s and
they you know it's hard for them to go
to the grocery store
the people that are obviously
you know running the whole situation i
mean
politics
obviously
money
that's the problem
that's the taxes
it uh you know you go across the border
in oregon
and right away it's a buck a gallon
cheaper so we're over taxed here yeah i
don't know what to say about our current
president he's uh
he's spending money as we used to say
when i was in the military like a
drunken sailor
so uh
it's like
it doesn't matter how much he spends he
just
he just prints more money and taxes more
of it you know which of course causes
inflation to go up it would be
beneficial to i'm sure to america if
he would uh you know
do something different you know i was
around in 1975 when inflation went crazy
you know i mean it went like 30 percent
you know 25-30 percent
so uh
most people a lot of people live they
don't remember that or they weren't born
then
so uh
it's going to take a definitely a bad
turn in this country
and it needs to stop so i think we just
need to like shift away from oil and get
more sustainable you know
automobiles you know or just do a lot
more bicycling and things like that yes
over the years you know it just it
fluctuates it goes up it goes down so
it's
you just kind of i guess i just think it
is what it is having a lot of taxes on
that commodity makes it really tough um
but you know you look at this area too
and the average price of a house is you
know a couple million bucks so
more more tax on those folks might be a
better way to work that out
our volume is very low
we have to pay for a 35 000 load in 10
days
paying four dollars a gallon for gas if
it's not marked up we're not going to be
able to pay for that